MIKE TOBIN, THANK YOU IN
CHICAGO TODAY.
>> Dana: TO THE BORDER CRISIS.
NEW REPORT REVEALING THE UNITED
STATES WILL START TRANSFERRING
SOME MIGRANT FAMILIES INTO ICE
CUSTODY AS BORDER FACILITIES
DEAL WITH OVERCROWDING.
SOME OF THEM OPERATING AT
NEARLY 600% ABOVE CAPACITY.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT IT IS FORMER
ACTING ICE DIRECTOR RON
VITIELLO.
TELL US IN YOUR MIND WHAT
HAPPENS, THE MIGRANTS END UP
GETTING TRANSFERRED TO ICE
CUSTODY.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT SITUATION
THEY’RE IN.
IF THEY ARE YOUNG CHILDREN
WITHOUT THEIR FAMILIES THEY
WILL HAVE A BRIEF STAY WITH
BORDER PATROL AND ON TO HHS
CUSTODY TO A SHELTER AND PLACED
IN THE UNITED STATES.
FAMILIES WITH OLDER CHILDREN
CAN BE EXPELLED CURRENTLY UNDER
TITLE 42 TO MEXICO.
FAMILIES WITH YOUNG CHILDREN
ARE BEING RELEASED IN RECORD
NUMBERS.
YOU HAVE SEEN THE IMAGES.
YOUR AUDIENCE HAS SEEN IMAGES.
THE MOST POWERFUL COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD IN 2021 AND WE CAN’T
DEVELOP POLICIES TO KEEP THIS
SURGE OF HUMANITY FROM COMING
TO OUR BORDERS EVERY DAY.
THE BORDER PATROL IS
OVERWHELMED.
YOU HEARD ABOUT CAPACITY
NUMBERS.
I FEEL BAD FOR MY FORMER
COLLEAGUES IN BORDER PATROL.
THEY KNOW SOLUTIONS EXIST.
WE DON’T HAVE THE POLITICAL
WILL IN CONGRESS OR
ADMINISTRATION TO FIX THE
PROBLEM.
THOSE INDIVIDUAL BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND NOW ICE ASSISTANCE
LEFT TO PICK UP THE PIECES AND
TERRIBLE CONDITIONS.
>> Dana: TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
ALSO.
CHRIS CABRERA IS THE BORDER
PATROL UNION VICE PRESIDENT
TALK THAN ON FOX NEWS ON
SATURDAY WITH THE ISSUE THAT
MANY OF THE MIGRANTS COULD BE
COVID POSITIVE BUT THEY DON’T
HAVE GOOD NUMBERS.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> NOT EVERYONE WE ENCOUNTER WE
TEST.
ONLY THOSE EXHIBITING SOME TYPE
OF SYMPTOMS.
NOT EVERYBODY HAS SYMPTOMS THAT
HAS IT AND WE’RE RELEASING
PEOPLE OUT THE DOOR.
DAY IN AND DAY OUT WITH ACTUAL
POSITIVE TESTS FOR COVID AND
MORE JUST KEEP POPPING UP.
>> Dana: WE HAVE THAT SITUATION
AND HERE ARE PICTURES OF
MIGRANTS BEING SMUGGLED IN IN
CARPET AND PLASTIC BINS.
102 DEGREES OUTSIDE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THERE, RON.
>> IT SHOWS YOU THE DISREGARD
THAT SMUGGLERS HAVE FOR
INDIVIDUALS AS THEY ARE
TRANSPORTING THEM.
THE CONDITIONS DOWN THERE
INSIDE THAT VEHICLE 102 DEGREES.
DURING A PANDEMIC FACE-TO-FACE
AND THEN CHRIS IS A FRONT-LINE
AGENT AND PART OF THE UNION
LEADERSHIP AND A FRIEND OF MINE.
HE KNOWS WHAT THE SOLUTIONS TO
THIS PROBLEM IS.
HE KNOWS WHAT THE CONTOURS ARE.
HE KNOWS THE JOB OF A BORDER
PATROL AGENT IS RISKY.
ON TOP OF THE THE OTHER RISKS
THEY DEAL WITH COVID.
PEOPLE IN THE PIPELINE ARE NOT
PRACTICING SOCIAL DISTANCING.
STASH HOUSES, TRUCKS,
OVERPACKED VEHICLES.
CHRIS KNOWS THE PROBLEM EXISTS
AND THE RISKS THE AGENT AND
THEIR FAMILIES FACE.
>> Dana: BIPARTISAN CALLS FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO PUT A NEW
BORDER CZAR IN CHARGE AND NOT
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS.
TAKE A LOOK AT SENATOR GRAHAM.
>> SHE DOESN’T KNOW WHAT SHE IS
DOING.
I DON’T DISLIKE HER BUT SHE IS
SUGGESTING WE SHOULD INVEST A
LOT OF MONEY IN THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES BUT NOT
CHANGE OUR BORDER POLICIES.
CONGRESSMAN CUELLAR’S DISTRICT
IS UNDER SIEGE.
HOSPITALS ARE GOING BETWEEN --
THERE IS COVID POSITIVES
EVERYWHERE.
IF WE DON’T GET NEW EYES ON
THIS PROBLEM THE WORST IS YET
TO COME.
>> Dana: YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> THERE IS CLEARLY NO INTEREST
AT THE WHITE HOUSE LEVEL
INCLUDING WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT TO FIX THIS PROBLEM.
AND SO LINDSEY GRAHAM AS A
FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CUELLAR IS A BORDER RESIDENT
AND REPRESENTED AND EVEN AS A
DEMOCRAT I AGREE WITH HIS
POLICY.
LET’S STOP THIS CHAOS AND FIX
THE PROBLEM AND PUT RESOURCES
IN PLACE SO IT ISN’T AS BAD AS
IT COULD BE.
CONGRESS COULD ACT HERE.
THEY COULD MOVE TOWARD GETTING
THE ADMINISTRATION TO GO BACK
TO THE MIGRANT PROTECTION
PROTOCOLS.
TO REENGAGE WITH THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE ON THE ASYLUM
PROTOCOLS.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE LEVEL THEY
AREN’T READY TO DO THAT YET.
THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING ELSE
DONE.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ACT TO
FORCE THIS MOVING FORWARD.
>> Dana: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CONDITIONS WITH THE PEOPLE
DEALING WITH PLUS BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND WHAT IS HAPPENING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IT IS HARD
TO IMAGINE HOW MORE -- WHAT YOU
NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO GET
WASHINGTON TO PAY ATTENTION AND
DECIDE TO ACT?
IT IS REALLY REMARKABLE TO ME